okay four people joining this live
stream we are in the late stages of
documenting and working through the
design for our database connectivity
framework for version 12 of language and
let's see okay so I think the first
things we have to discuss are some names
of functions um and the first one of
those is merged entity class right and
the proposal is to change that to join
the cross Mantic class correct
I'm joined across that TD class what's
your proposal last time well does it do
I mean I'm joined across is not my
absolutely full time favorite name but
it's the one the stain on remind us what
was your objection to merged entity
class which doesn't do the same thing as
merge
it does what join across does yeah okay
so that's the answer I mean there I mean
if we look at what merge does it's
something different yeah this is through
but we do not base all these names very
closely after Wolfram language names of
the operation but okay fine but then
explain to me what merged if I look at
merged entity class it tells you rather
concisely what it does semantically
because it creates entities which have
properties from both the you know both
classes which are being merged yeah but
on the other hand the signature is
actually pretty close to one the one of
China trois
well except China cross is not the best
name either yeah um I mean unmerge
combined values with the same key no
it's definitely not doing what merge is
doing well explain that for a second in
is
you
okay so let's walk through what this
really does by merging the properties of
pairs of entities
what is this saying by merging the
properties of pairs of entities of class
one and class two entities
is that a mistake wording mistake though
yeah I think it's a mistake
the class rent is obtained by merging is
there other no examples of this thing
not yet
I'm emerging probably is a passive
angeles-class one um
merging the properties of pairs of
entities so you can just have a hold
wield no no no no I just I just edited
it you didn't see I just edited it so we
didn't finish this page it's the first
time we look at it
okay but the ones with asterisks
asterisks are ones where the ones
without asterisks we didn't look at it
all yeah they're virgin okay okay well
maybe we should go to the guide page to
start off with
oh wow this isn't even finished
nope
oh shoot well okay this page comes from
which other page it's working
it comes from the the general page about
working with databases is that correct
yes
you
okay so let me find
okay so this page
oh boy so there's a bunch of stuff
missing on this page as well okay all
right great
okay well into action we go um all right
is this page reasonably complete okay
let's let's deal with this page first
okay
you
okay so that's a completely wrong
description at the top there
you
you
okay that's just dumb
well let's rather we just need to write
some text here that explains basically
what the deal is now here
um entity based data storage okay direct
data storage okay relational database
operations so this is
um it will be nice to communicate that
these are well this is obviously read
right because it has SQL update okay a
connection to an external obviously okay
so let's see what so first of all I
don't think there's a good reason to
call this SQL database subject I think
we should just call it database object
and well I mean the question is really
whether we want to do 12 other types of
database objects later yes we do but I
mean it's it's a it the the object can
identify can self identify what kind of
a database it's dealing with that's very
tricky the problem is that all this
stuff is going to be I mean already the
function I do entity store is defined
across two different packets if we also
define as that base are you telling me
are you telling me some detailed
implementation thing look right now
where I'm I'm telling was something
about I'm telling you something about
how the current Pacolet match works I
don't care and the design for the sake
of some detail but then then fix the
bucket manager know not introduced we
cannot introduce interrogative
dependencies like that because then if
one packet updates and the other fails
to update we will get in some broken
state you can't have functions defined
like that across different packets
easily call on a live stream help points
out that SQL database object something
like graph database object will be quite
different which is true what is the I
mean the thing that here this is an RDF
store I mean what is the other thing I
think we should just call this database
object and we will cross the bridge
later of what of how we dispatch the
thing you know probably the right way to
do it is to internally dispatch I'm
gonna tell you implementation details
let's not do that internally you can
just dispatch you have this one function
database object and you internally
dispatch it to SQL database object or
whatever else but still
that's exactly the problem that Carlo
outlined the question I'm not I don't
want to hear about this I don't want to
hear about your details of Pacolet
manager dependencies it is not relevant
that's not just details - and that will
affect the entire operation of thanks
okay you know what are you telling me
that we can't name this function the way
it should be named because of some
detail about how you're implementing
things that's not gonna work
no it's it's about the detail about how
bad let's work okay I doesn't matter
okay so the fact is we're not gonna have
something other than an SQL database for
a while during that time we're gonna fix
how whatever it is that you're I mean if
you really want me to go look at the
code I'll go look at the code I'm
certain there's a way to fix it but
let's not go there okay and I think this
should be renamed
you
the Arcola a live stream is helpfully
pointing out relational database object
would be a reasonable thing to call this
absolutely would be probably better yeah
but then why do we have a cool database
connection and why do we have a little
miss connection doesn't need to be
specific so the point is that the way
Tony implemented things is that there is
an interface for the entity store and
that's why RDF store is not called
entity story because either you call it
something different or it contains an
object that identifies what it is okay
what else like in a [ __ ] case right now
we have this rather weird [ __ ] Connect
thing right mm-hmm
but we could I mean I think we had this
[ __ ] stuff and there is a way to
subsume much of that into this only the
SQL database object would be a [ __ ]
database object and it would be
different but what would we call it if
this was called relational database
object what would we call them on go on
[ __ ] why why yes I understand that but
are we saying that there is no category
of thing what is it what what is the
category in the case of I'm sorry wait
wait wait a second [ __ ] in because of
[ __ ] [ __ ] could be relational or could
be not relational depends on how you set
it up so you can you can define a [ __ ]
database with a schema and you can find
other bits without scheme no but you can
really define foreign keys and this is
what relation is still I can know
Ricardo that's not what real authorities
relation means table relational algebra
doesn't mean foreign keys
then he's closed a livestream is
pointing out that objects store is kind
of the category for MongoDB
documents stories on object store object
store yeah they're also referred at what
is thought installment as well that's
true that's a horrible name though
well this should certainly not be called
SQL database object because that even
confuses it relative to all these direct
SQL operations
the question of whether it should be
cool I think no you interrupt there is a
difference in in RDF they make a
distinction between a store which is RDF
and the great language we see sparkle in
a scale there has never been such a
distinction like they call the SQL both
the source and the prey language so okay
well look SQL database object is clearly
not the right name so the question is
because I guess since we call this
relational database operations we could
reasonably justify calling this
relational database object that'll be
good enough I think if you are so much
against the SQL database object I am
here all right Thank You Kyle for
helping us on that one
you
we got another posture layer was
database schema object because it really
just contains the schema but I'm happy
with database sorry with relational
database object as well
yes
right well then so represents well if
the database inspect no it's not the
rollout it's the result of database
connection isn't it
no no connection the abyss connection
works like file or URL it's a completely
lazy thing so it's not the fact that you
have a connection object doesn't even
mean that developes exists so you give
database connection to the database
inspect and you get back a relational
database objects can you say can you
show me an example of can you can you
send me an example please do you still
have in your Dropbox that SQLite file I
have no idea um what would it look like
what was it what was it called it was
called something like demo dot SQLite
called demo okay so what should I do
with this okay
open the book with the one that is in
the same folder okay and I think that in
there you don't need to do all that
stuff anymore oh yeah like this yeah and
that what's that well that's because of
our notes stuff that you have installed
yeah
should I mean it's also an internal
function that has a terrible name oh
okay all right
that's better all right okay so now if I
say database can end database inspect of
this
what is gonna happen here I have to wait
a little bit because the build scripts
are not yet up to date and so it
stretches in Java which has terribly
longer startup time all right so what is
this thing now
so that thing represents the schema so
it contains information about all the
tables and all the columns in every
table some meta information this is cool
database connection wasn't this cool
database schema good because yeah I mean
that's another possibility schema
doesn't quite communicate the fact that
it has methods and stuff extract well
what does it have what what can I do
with this now
yeah it's saying gravitation so I look
here and I could say something like
columns right no columns you can't say
columns you have to see tables first
columns so it's each thing or you can
ask columns okay and and then you can
say nice from columns so if I say down
here like this or do is it curried all
rights like that could it be curried it
could no wait
no because when you do me well I guess
you could but we would have something
that has to return an evaluated first
okay with this I'm not sure if it's a
great idea to carry it yeah okay now
when it says table nay tables here is
there not a symbolic representation of
those tables I mean let's say I want to
get one of those tables and turn it into
a data set for example how would I do
that
we used to Howard but then we decided
that we'll always have just this schema
object itself okay but just tell me how
to get one of those tables like the
nation table into a data set but you
wonder data
I want to tell you set which is the data
of there is no there is no way to
examine no no no there is a way with m50
value you can register the whole thing
and then say so if you register so you
can now do this and this register of an
T store of kima what for the entity
store and the store off of schema opens
credit schema and now if you want now
you can do entity value of nation and
then any property association maybe and
then data set or just data set just
works so those are basically foreign
keys to another table is that correct
reverse foreign keys but yes they are
foreign keys in the other table to this
one that's why there is the glasses and
not seen single entities this flow seems
like it should be an easier one to that
is another way what wouldn't okay let me
just ask you for the examples how are we
representing that SQLite thing um is it
is it from example data or how are we
actually presenting it for example so we
are we're putting a cleaned-up version
but how is it going to be accessed
through examples or something else I
think that the the current consensus is
that it's going to work just like the
things that are in import and so it's
gonna be something like file example
data slash fella based on SQLite okay
okay it will be really good if we get
that in there so that we can actually
start playing with these things I'm
writing the examples um I'm betting on
our live stream is saying that the
entity value comma dataset will work on
all entities stores that's very helpful
I agree it's a nice feature and I'm not
sure why we're um so are you telling me
if I say entity value of for example cat
breed comma data set what will I get
here well I get a a giant thing with a
bunch of pictures of cow my god okay so
I will it will turn it into a data set
basically yes do we document that a
minute let's take a look by the way we
should also make this into some kind of
workflow so people have a fighting
chance
okay oh wow you know whoever wrote this
this violates our principles about how
these things should be written
how did this get written I I don't even
know okay so that's wrong so this is
actually the second argument and you
didn't document that so those strings
like property Association or data set or
even Association they can appear in the
second or third argument most so that
doesn't say it yeah okay okay so we got
a different issue here
you
um okay so it's this by the way these
things here are all irrelevant now is
that true or not the third one is still
relevant and the first full ones don't
seem relevant first to hear correct
I'm not sure if it's explicitly set
anywhere that you can have an entity
class in the first document of achieve
that something we certainly should
update with the newer stuff like entity
class and all the anti-claus like heads
it's actually the preferred way of using
them relevant there in 21st well okay
but what does it give you for the entity
class basically the same as if you had
or supplied the list of entities right
so in fact this documentation isn't
really right so we should say gives the
value of the specified property so for
an entity here its equivalent
um
this is equivalent to entity Open
bracket property correct
right yeah but doesn't say that here
it's actually the opposite its entity
over the square bracket property which
is a shorthand of that I am I understand
I understand we don't say it here though
okay so we got multiple points to make
here so the value specified property for
the given entity um entity of property
is equivalent to enter the value entity
property
um now
for
you know I think that's what we have to
say
well then I think that if possible I
would really like the second usage
message to say something about class
like I'm going to say that I'm gonna say
and then details you should say that
it's that doesn't only apply about 20
now I'm going to say this hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on I mean this
is a mess what we have here so
um this is the next thing to say right
and that property um
gives a list of the values of the
specified property for all entities in
the specified class is that correct yes
okay now the next thing we want to
document
you
how can we have
[Music]
so what happens if you give a list of
entities here
actually maybe we should document second
that case of entity one entity to
property okay I think it's better if
that comes after class because we want
to give people otherwise people think
that the canal more canonical form is to
get the entities out first which they
should not try to be fast work that
assumes that you always top of the class
yeah which you don't necessarily
um I think we should do it this way we
can say that one shouldn't do this for I
mean hold on a second property um now
I'm gonna ask the question when you have
this case here which is the which is
first which is the table which is which
is which are the rows which are the
columns it's the outer product of the
two lists okay the entities verse okay
all right okay you get the first you get
the a row of properties okay
gives a list
- values
which which makes me makes me wonder
shouldn't we have a modifier that does
the transpose for a packing problem
purposes like column-oriented should be
more efficient in many cases yes but we
are trying to get a bunch of
column-oriented functions created and
that's a separate discussion
it was the list of values and specified
property for each of the entity I now
somebody's gonna ask what order are they
gonna come out in for the class that's
the that's the thing which which is an
issue here okay
gives the list of values of the
specified property
for all entities in the specified class
okay now we have to say
[Music]
okay here we want to say let's say end
nearly it gives a list of property
values for each entity I know but let's
first of all gives gives the list of
values of the property I for the
specified entity and then the final case
is um
[Music]
enter the value of n comma
so here
you
you know what I would prefer to say
okay all right all right fine we can
just say property one so now tell me
what the skills
gives a list of the values of the
property I
gives the list of values of the property
I well no wait a minute
is it a list well maybe you should not
see ends he should say something like I
mean because it's like it's it's
subsumes in there one entity or lease 20
I just did the one entity case right
here yeah but then it subsumes the other
two both I don't care what it subsumes
we're talking about the multiple entity
case here okay this is the multiple
entity case so just tell me which way
round it is it is the outer most list is
the entities right yes yes or at least
for each hence it gives the list of
values of the property I for each
gives
here's the list of the values of the
property I
gives the list of the values of the
property I for each of the entities
but represented by ants right that is
that easy to understand which way around
it is talking about I think so well yes
just happened there
I don't know why the spellchecker still
thinks it's active on this um okay okay
so now here um this is irrelevant why is
this even in here I don't understand why
this is in here this is irrelevant to
this
agreed um
now now you should add detail that says
someone should have a detail that says
that in an T value class property class
can be one of the following heads which
are what which are anti class sorted NT
glass sample NT class extended NT glass
joined across and C glass filter dental
assets agreed what is this nonsense here
this is clearly wrong what is this this
is nonsense okay
by the way is it the case that this can
be a pure
that can be answered a value of a quoted
string of an entity type is that correct
yeah that's a shorthand for so you
didn't document that well this is a mess
I'm sorry I'm kind of upset about this
are these other ones a mess as well
you
this is just nonsense and it's just
nonsense right
I think it's nonsense they're from the
time when we originally fought them and
not has changes them but originally lnu
me be all looked at them yeah okay well
this clearly needs a complete rewrite
okay alright let's come back
um
you
so we were saying that we need to say
something that we in the entity value
class from a property second I need to
get
okay sorry go ahead huh so so this is
this needs a bunch of okay let's let's
just unravel our stack for a second here
so we're doing this now the thing we
were looking at before was this
relational database object
and what we were looking at by the way
some on our live stream asks the very
reasonable question what does import of
demo SQLite do
what is that importer if you just import
the thing what does it do let's create
an entity store presumably it should
return an entity store I mean that's
that's debatable because there are two
things to problems first of all is that
it's not importing the whole thing so
you don't get the full date out
what if you just told this truth board
the whole thing wait wait wait so I
think it should have elements and we
should decide what the default element
is you might want to get the raw data
out without anything wrapped in it just
as an association of associations or at
least some associations actually saying
that you might want to get something
which is just the schema description and
no yes way so it should have like an
element that is the relational database
object another element that is the empty
store what I couldn't have wait a minute
is that is it possible for it to have
the relational database object because
because it's then still have to refer to
the external file wouldn't it yeah so
the relational database object has one
once you it still contains developes
connection okay let me point out that an
import string is that not equivalent to
import what said if you take take the
bytes of the SQLite file you're telling
me that relational database object
cannot point to something in memory
that's what you're basically it can it
can as a matter of fact there is it's
actually a yet different case because
SQLite supports databases that are
completed in memory okay be empty anyway
we can we can add stuff very important I
guess there would be a bunch of
different possible elements you can get
out of SQLite file including the full
data as just raw stuff or a data set
hold on let's let's go back to this
documentation because we need to okay so
this should be um
[Music]
so it's either entity there or its
entity class right
we're antique
no it's its class generic class which is
one of the new heads that we are told
what class is that so class can be
either NC glass or sorta lanta class or
simple than two glass extended etc okay
so okay there's equivalent to enter the
value of end when end now why don't you
make a different detail where you say in
entity value class comma property class
can be and then we put the table with
the same and they link to the other in
well entity value and comma dot dot and
can be any of the following yes okay so
so the first thing it can be is that as
an explicit is just entered a so it just
be entity of type or do we not even say
what it is oh I mean just because the
the first argument can be a complex
class itself right um a single entity
but right yeah okay okay next entity
class no next for ELISA lenses well okay
no let's put that as a generic because
that's that we can have a list of entity
classes as well so let's not draw the
life we can well why don't you tell me
what it can do with entity class here so
this is entity cost right mm-hmm
and that would say something like a
named or implicit ends in class
okay what else can it be
sort identity class well we can't be any
of those kinds of entities yeah I was
just gonna list them I don't know what
you want to start with yeah okay but but
can't it be an entity function on the
outside of all of this no no the the
second argument can be enhance the
function okay so then we the next thing
we're going to say is in entity value of
nth comma prop prop can be any of the
following so among the things that so
wait a minute you also can have a type
name here right independent of a single
entity and entity class and then
somewhere at the bottom of all of this
is so you've got a bunch of these kinds
of things like sort identity class
cetera right
oh what the heck just happened here why
is this there's some bug here this
jumped what is this doing
to see you see what this did cook could
somebody
humorous but not useful right every time
I add something to this it's jumping
down to some other part of the document
could um okay okay okay now somewhere at
the bottom of all of this we want to
give both the list case
well you're saying that I should
document the multiple a list of entities
at the top here you think
and you will follow the usage messages
I'm not a big fan of these scientists to
be honest but sure why not
why don't we put at the bottom I mean
there's also the type which is all
entities of a given type right or meta
properties of the type so there again
what do you mean
it means that for example if you ask for
properties you don't get and that's also
kind of an exception to the shape of
what you get out so hold on that's
that's a completely different thing what
we're saying here is there's a list of
entities and it cannot be a list of
entity classes apparently right no it
can't
it cannot okay I mean we we will I think
in the future we want to add something
like entity joined entity class and
Union the entity class and intersected
empty class and complimented entity
class to do set operations or multiple
entity classes but not me
all right so then this thing here um all
entities over the given of the given
type of the specified type right okay so
here we've got all of these other things
the merged etc teru teru teru etc okay
so now there are a couple of other
things I think like dated anti group
down here in the first one and this one
was dated is dated something relevant
you know who can eat an entity also as
well as a property okay so I don't know
exactly what they are because Tony
they're stated and chill variant and
there's
those paws are rappers and then there's
another category like entity group and
entity copies which one is the one that
is qualified with the quantity like if
you want on Rama flower entity instance
it is some mixture of all of them so
with it so you're saying that in this
table we should be adding so let's make
a note because the stupid thing is gonna
jump like crazy entity instance entity
group entity copies also dated and geo
variant yes
okay
all right well arguably what we should
have is the relational things at the top
followed by this list all entities
addressed by type then we should go into
the entity instance stuff do you think
what do you think what do you think that
should I don't even want to distract
with the entity instance right at the
top yes there's some how different
things could be two categories
as a matter of fact maybe we should
split this and say something like
because auntie instance is something
that you can continually store and like
it works it quacks like Mandy you're not
like an entity class so you can put it
in a list okay what about the other ones
like entity group and the group it works
like yes okay so by default these ones
will behave like a single entity is that
correct
yeah so well dated can be wrapped around
and the class as well right yes no but
I'm saying in terms the value that comes
out the certain set of things will give
a single value and other sets of things
will give a list of values
yes except for the wrappers like dated
that in which case I understand I
understand I am stunned okay so
okay so let's see um
okay entity value
um
[Music]
well here if we say prop property here
the following okay if I say in entity
value of n comma prop
p'tee the following forms for nth
give a single value
as a result okay whereas then we would
say
you
give a list of values as a result
that reasonable thing to say
okay so now here
you
I'm gonna put a whole bunch of these in
since this isn't jumping down um for
whatever reason okay
so then the first thing that goes there
these two things both gonna
right and this goes there correct
yes
you
okay so now here a single entity all
right so now what's the next thing here
it'll be like an entity instance right
we could also follow some graphics
documentation that we say the following
rappers can be used because dated is a
rapper that can rap a single or multiple
sings I know but that's a separate
that's a separate thing it's a separate
place okay we can deal with that
separately okay let's let's sum I'm
asking for this table here what are we
giving we're giving entity then entity
instance entity group etc is that
correct
is that correct so entity instance of a
list of entities not what it would not
give a single result
what about entity group yes that will
give us a
result yes why can't you give an entity
group of a list of entities as well
yes entity group of a list or a class of
entities
okay look
this doesn't talk about entity this
doesn't talk about entity classes does
it
it needs to
okay so are you telling you that the
only thing which gives a single
I mean entity instance of an entity
right that will give a single result
yes lect okay as we'll all those other
ones as will date it of an entity
correct yes okay
okay is there anything other than just
an individual entity or one of these
rappers that will give a single result
entity copyists
I'm sorry I that's a rapper
that's a wraparound entity right yes
I'm asking I'm going to ask the question
again is there anything
this is a single named entity right it
cannot be an implicit entity
correct
it could be an implicit entity no it
could not be an implicit entity because
an implicit entity is an entity class
hmm an implicit entity is an entity
class with an aggregation applied to it
okay so let's be specific then we have
to break this out about whether it's an
entity with a name or an implicit or an
A+ identity
am i making sense
we could just say a single entity
no because we got to tell people what to
do am I making sense
um okay I think all the things were said
entity should behave in a certain way
and the entity recognized how you can
specify single entities so every girl
would um I think that all the things we
said entity should behave in a certain
way independent of how they are
specified either by name or by a list of
conditions so that's why I think it's up
to the entity ref to list all the ways
you can specify a single entity alright
so
in this list of properties here this is
again going to be a you know
Ethan our livestream is saying we should
think about airing a tutorial all these
functions are extremely confusing yeah
we know it's complicated
um do we have a tutorial coming for the
stuff I'll work for yes also tutorial
maybe yeah why not well there's two
different things I mean one is the whole
Toni related entity store stuff and the
other is all the interactions with
relational databases actually oh we
wanted to discuss that with you
separately soon because we need
someplace where we would show how to use
the query language for the databases and
how it translates into primitives known
in databases and obviously for just the
entity framework part is not the right
place where we can put it
heck no no so look that's exactly what
our tech note series is supposed to be
for that's what it should be
we don't really have things called
tutorials in quotes anymore we have tech
notes and monographs so depending on the
scope it's either a tech note or mono
cough that sounds like a tech note to me
yeah like mostly I don't know how you
would categorize it but imagine that we
need mostly kind of a guide for the
query language what would it be tech
notes I'm sorry what are you talking
about you talking about our query
language you're talking about
translation to SQL oh no we're talking
about our query language but the thing
is that for databases we can't compile
everything so we'll have to explain how
to use it right yeah I mean like a tech
note to me you'd have to write it um
yeah I'll go ahead and write it I just
needed to know what category it should
belong to yeah okay okay okay okay
um okay
the name of a property right can be any
of the following a property
the property with a specified name for
the type of entity
properties
I mean this is with a specified name for
the type of entity that we're dealing
with right yes
this one
you
you
n
there's entity property which normally
has a type as its first argument is that
correct or cannot have other things its
first argument and typed that's all it
cannot have a computer right it can have
wait wait
it's not this is ODS drink well that
second will part is a string correct
that correct the second argument is
always a string
you
you
you
okay now the property here okay so these
properties also can have things like
dated rappers right yes
okay so you think right so
for aunt gives a single entity as a
result so that's just us um this is just
the only such thing
so actually I mean
I think we should put it in here
you
so then this becomes
africanus sake ah that's just a thing
that says here a single entity
then we go and as to class
okay so most likely this is a nothing
tying forms Fant can be used okay so
then we get all these things like sort
identity class and so on
okay
the following rappers
you
um
[Music]
can be used to to well so that basically
is going to be a table
and to the instance entity group entity
copies and then dated in geo variant
right and then there's going to be
wrappers for this one as well correct
because the the entity the thing the
entity variant Stoops that's not what I
wanted um
okay so this is we say things like
entity instance
of aunt
you
Oh , and then it's got properties there
right it's got got the instancing
information particular a particular
instance of nth eg quantity of etc
okay so then we've got um entity group
what is entity group group two again
what does it take as an argument a list
or class of entities
okay so entity copies we can give
earlier
yes it sort of says question how many
does it have just n yes
um
you
you
modified entities and the entity classes
okay all right entity group what does
that take
list or class of entities
what does it mean
it means if you have for instance two
entities with an extensive mast and the
group has the sum of the masses its mass
okay representation well this should be
you
you
um
[Music]
a single entity formed from the group of
entities hence is that right yes
you
okay so then we have the dated and geo
variant is that correct yes
you
we'll worry about how those are is that
it or other other modifiers I think it's
it but I check okay
all right now when we get down here
by the way this isn't right right this
is this is ents
props annotation correct that last thing
here
right yes
yes I think the list of entity wrappers
is complete okay okay
you
you
well should we say an annotation
um
of the value or what should we say there
yes it's an annotation of the value
correct so but there are different
concepts so right now their entity
Association property Association they
are also listed on our annotations and
this might be confusing this annotation
we mean things like the date at which a
particular value was measured no that's
terrible the thing you just mentioned is
terrible so um I don't know whether this
should be called the annotation we mean
something completely different by
annotation elsewhere
[Music]
it's a result type basically
no it's basalt property
well it's the what are you saying it's
the property of the property it's it's
the poverty of the polity value well
let's see some examples so that's
probably not the right thing there so
let's but just put a little xxx there so
we know that um so basically there are
two types of examples okay but hold on
down here these are things that can go
in the second argument is that correct
yes so this is nonsense basically
what
you
are you sure that this should be the
same function
in general we could have an entity type
value entity class value and so on no
I'm asking whether entity properties for
example isn't that we don't have that
we do what does that do it's a list of
properties of the type so that's
equivalent to is this taking forever
forever
that's equivalent to this weird entity
value okay so among other things it's
equivalent to the properties sub value
right we should figure out why this is
taking forever in this version Oh
something came back why did it take
forever
you should check into that something is
wrong there
makes sense yes can you check into that
do I need to send mail okay I mean
something is wrong probably next caching
system is not doing the right thing for
this case will be my guess okay in any
case
what we haven't said
here
this equivalence between entity you know
the sub value thing needs to be
emphasized more
most of these that will just work right
am i making sense yes and in that's also
the reverse sub value property of entity
you have a person worked for the string
case correct and also not if you have a
list of entities so in each of these
things like sort identity costs we
probably should document the sub value
piece right so like with the entity we
certainly need to document the sub value
do we
you
yeah I mean this should be an entity
without the double quotes there for the
type
and we also desperately need to document
okay what we do document that
okay
I don't think we should say this is it
even true I mean is that going to be
true when you have a construct
identities is that just a hack for this
particular case
Tony you mean this list of types yes
those are things that we call now
something like base types and but that's
not this is the total hack that entity
value open/close returns this correct no
I think it's a total hockey the analogy
is originally when we practice we
usually return a list of things to start
with that means in the case or I know a
country gonna open close transform data
you get a single service an entity value
is so to say a super thing of those
things where you get two types well in
that if that I mean I think that it this
would be nice and symmetrical fancy list
was just an T value with one argument
okay all right
so I want to come back to
so we're going to this page is a mess we
don't need to do it but we need to zoom
out for a second and to this page here
and actually the page we were starting
on we're even zooming out further
because we're starting on the page about
um databases in general
come
okay so we need to rewrite this
obviously
but let's not do that right now because
we probably got high priority things to
do but that needs to be done okay
Andrea who's sorry who is who is peeing
here okay so you need to make sure you
have that on the list please and for the
next time we meet I want to have a boom
boom boom this is the specific list of
things that we know we have to do okay
so
okay relational database is the word
operations the right word
now okay all right so database inspect
what is database inspect really and is
that the right word for it I think it is
I mean cannot really think about the
other one it's actually doing this
operation of doing several query not
there to know what's inside it so no I
know but really what it's going to do is
it's going to return a relational
database object so inspect suggests to
me that it will bring up a GUI which is
not what it's doing at all right did
sense yes right and I believe that
there's even in that this database
Explorer thing is a GUI right to do
something similar to database inspect
well there is a first document for this
guy then that allows you to sell a
actually seven document table table
table so maybe we can have something
that says interactive who goes to draw
in the future and I don't know it's it's
it's showing to your GUI and let's use a
different function I mean this
particular function I don't really
believe in the name of this I think it's
just the wrong name I think it suggests
something completely different okay
this is the wrong name what it actually
does is to return this thing and I don't
even think that's the right name because
what
that is if I'm understanding correctly
is that is a handle to what a particular
element of the relational database right
either a table or it represents some
meta information about the database that
would be correct statement and it has
methods to extract specific information
about the objects in the day of the
database such as tables or columns
sitter right what is database inspector
I don't think it's what you think it is
so to speak
do we have something similar in the
system I don't understand why it isn't
just relational database object apply to
the database connection what is it doing
are different from that the second
argument is important when you have like
a huge databases sometimes it like with
100 tables maybe even more you need to
select manually what are the tables that
you want to get back analyze it will
take forever okay well why don't you
just put that on the second argument a
relational database object
and they returned so in other words
relational database object of the data
there is still there is one potential
problem with that which is that we were
thinking of relational database object
as being a completely nerved
representation of things without any
relation semantics and if we have a it
doesn't make any sense to have a
function that has a name that suggests
it doesn't completely different that all
it does is to go from the database
connection to the relational database
object it's not really a critical aspect
but but I would I would like to have a
function that allows you to select we
need that okay but but so maybe this is
has the wrong name okay okay so
first of all
as database connection specific the heck
is that
the heck is that look if this is
specifically for a relational database
and not for something else it shouldn't
be called database connection but
student for this one
we might be able later to generalize to
non-relational databases because this
one has less fewer constraints in terms
of how to extend it and it will be far
easier to do them for say relational
database objects to extend to other
types so this one will be fine to become
more general in the future ok ok so but
what we get returned by
this database connection right
then need something to be turned into
a thing that that what that we can then
use so that the workflow is you're
saying entity register of entity store
so what is entity store of that so
you're going to say entities store of
this thing this relational database
object is that correct what does that
mean
Koni that means so in theory the full
form would be at the store very
complicated association of the database
object the and if you put it with just
the database objects the big association
will get auto-generated I don't
understand I'm sorry I don't understand
it so okay listen practical point we're
not gonna get this done and we were
already over time for this meeting we're
not gonna get this done tomorrow I'm not
around for half the day
we are running into a problem here
because we've got a bunch of things that
need to be renamed and rearranged let's
concentrate on those
okay I don't really believe in this I'm
sorry I don't really believe this
database connection thing
okay that's returning
is that if I look at the input form of
that that's not in really complicated
yes that is just as is very good
processor right okay we
okay so it seems to me that what we
should be doing is if indeed we have
this thing relational database object of
that connection and that either gives
this thing here
or if it's a connection ,
specific tables I mean this is assuming
you see it doesn't make any sense
because the fact is you're inspect thing
is like the word inspect does not
suggest that it already knows what
tables there are there in order to do
this with specific table names you have
to already know what the tables there
are right
yes but that's have much fewer
information than knowing all the
information about those tables this
thing it's a lazy object anyway so I
mean it what you do is you get
relational wait wait database connection
is easily the object relational database
object it's not one we could also add
something like second argument of the
business specs is just a number we need
to get the first three things we need to
go gate let's get rid of it I just don't
makes any sense
okay I mean it's not we can live without
it but one thing the dysfunction could
do for example the second argument can
be properties like URL read like you
know it can be just directly the
probability so you can see let me get
back the tables name like you're
suggesting let's get back to table I
don't know why database connection
doesn't have the capability to have
properties are stupid but which
properties of the database a which
connects I would think so yes but still
when the thing is that connection is a
completely you know symbolic can earth
handle to the connection so it's not
necessarily that it's connected
and if you would be asking this directly
from a connection the old cow makes
different things together so connection
is really not it shouldn't have this
semantic law that I think it should be
something that you use to get the thing
then on our live stream points out that
database inspect is more like database
properties which is true one other thing
about database inspect is that if ever
we have the similar operation for other
backends then it will not become it will
become less trivial because depending on
the type of the backend it will it will
return in different types of metal
objects such as maybe whatever other
objects will be for other databases with
the meta information yeah yeah but we
don't have any idea what we're gonna do
with that yet um okay look
the issue here is we've got the Stata
base connection it is like the file
wrapper or the URL wrapper it does
pretty much nothing right
that correct well it does certain
processing and it also is pointing
frequently to some actual object
connection object that is vanished don't
take off education information for
example yes it does as we we just didn't
do it in this example but in general yes
it does okay yeah there is a password I
mean another thing that is doing which
is something we should probably separate
if this was actually me not from Paris
to the liberation of connect and
disconnect yes yes the connection the
actual connection now is done lazily but
the disconnection you might want to do
it once you have done otherwise we don't
have any capability for that right now
do we
that's who I mean we used to have
database connect are you saying we might
need a database disconnect sometimes
it's necessary unless function so we
don't have it set up so we have any
possibility in that function well what
we are currently using is a string
method of database connection which is
something called to connect or
disconnect or connect which can be
documented as a part of the basic and I
didn't see that in the documentation
well we so far keep these things
undocumented because connection
management is a low-level activity and
most of the time things are handled
automatically I don't think that's the
right way to do it at all a property of
database connection that says disconnect
no way that's not really a possible
thing probably not but now this is just
a bad idea okay let's go back around
this again okay so so I'm just gonna
summarize the things that are a mess
right now
okay so database connection and um
[Music]
all right
so the things that we still need to sort
out
filter density clause
potentially being called select identity
class
right because filter identity class is
basically the same operation as select
what what and we haven't looked at this
page have we
No
okay the fact that that is documented as
an entity function
you're telling me that this can't be an
ordinary function is that correct no but
it can be a property
well you haven't documented that hmm so
it can be a boolean property right
you
so
I do not like the word filtered we have
not used it elsewhere
we'll be aggregated either different
enough from group by that we cannot
called grouped by inst class filter
dancing class works trust like select so
we could call it select entity class
except for the fact that entity function
isn't a general function of course
that's true throughout but also selected
entity class sounds a little bit like
it's a specific class already existing
that you select yeah yeah alright I'm
warming to this name although I don't
really like it and about aggregated
entity class in group by the aggregation
as optional while in aggregated entity
class the grouping is optional so I
think the name is correct okay
merged entity class we come back to this
one
combined entity cloths what is it again
it's an operation where you're basically
getting two entity classes two sets of
entities and you create new entities
that contain properties for both from
entities of both classes both times so
you can order it entities you know
you're kind of merging two types of
entities into a single one that's why we
call it more originated class what are
the entities that you get out so for
example you get you can merge country
and city on capital city and you get
entities that there is one for each
conference case and they evolved the
properties of the country and all the
properties of the capital city sorry why
is it properties of the I don't
understand if you merged country and
city why do you get things which are
part of country rather than things that
are part of city the first and second
argument are perfectly symmetrical
another example would be imagine you
have a list of people and a list of
books and you want to merge them by elf
or ship and then you would get you know
for fridge fresh first on a book so each
can have multiple authors and person can
have author multiple things but for each
tuple of person or not and book you get
told the properties of 1+1 the
prophecies of the seven and the
just like Jonah cross so if you want to
follow this up they not quite because
any going doesn't accept function as a
lost argument well they will they will
do it okay
what would happen if we call it combined
entity class I think that that is
confusing because the problem when you
say combine into class is that why is is
it combined vertical or horizontal yeah
that's well okay but merge doesn't help
that in my view no doesn't really help
it so what is the right term for this
it's really a join yeah it's a join in
the sense of SQL but but language is
join no it's not it's join across which
is a name that we've got from the world
of relational databases so what is it
outside of that world what would you in
everyday language call this operation I
wish there are some examples here that
would help us
of merging the properties see your
emerging the properties you look you're
as much merging the properties now
you're joining the properties well yeah
yeah well maybe maybe better thing to
say is that you're merging entities so
you're kind of taking you're getting one
entity from basically two previous
entities so to speak one entity from two
previous entities explain that again to
me well if you have for example the
country Italy and the capital city Rome
then these were two entities which were
like separate entities of different
types yes you are combining them and
you're getting the entity that contains
properties and values of those
properties for both of these right but
then that becomes like an entity yes yes
that becomes like an entity but it's
like an entity that's sort of a merged
entity that contains both
you
I understand but this merging with
respect to a property yes that is with
respect to the no look that isn't right
it's just not right this is what what
you said was take your country example
that property is a property of class 1
is it not
yes but it now becomes also no no no no
no no but read the documentation it's
completely obscure right so in the case
where you just said you want to take you
know let's say class 1 is his country's
class 2 is cities and property is
capital cities of countries am I making
sense yes so this is a property of the
country that's right but that's not then
a property then what that what this
returns is entities that are the capital
sir
of countries let me make let me give you
a more imagine you you you take the
countries in the cities and self merging
them on a property you want to take all
the cities that ours
closer than a certain epsilon in
population to the corresponding country
there might be multiple matches you know
you know what I need some examples of
this okay this this this function I need
examples okay do you have examples in
the demo that we were that you were
actually or a opening there should the
examples we are really really really
running out of time here um okay so this
is a remaining thing this name isn't
right we need to figure out what it
should be but do we make a decision in
the Pfister's entity class is still not
I'm sorry the filter density class I'm
okay with the merged entity class I'm
not okay okay
you
you
you
where is this what's called ran across
yeah what the heck is this doing this is
just to represent it in the wait but
this is making a data set out of this is
that right yes yeah look there are some
values Stephen that's why it's forget
that is it it's me they decide out of
data it's calling NC value I see okay by
the way on this page we should make it
very clear that gosh this really should
document things like this on this page
okay
what is this
I don't understand
I don't understand with us killing us
what is this I don't understand why
don't you evaluate it just just write
merged and see classes that lengthy turn
across evaluated
okay I don't know what this is doing
okay so now for each person has a
foreign key to nation so well now we're
getting for each person now you can
access all the properties of nation so
instead of so this case was full name
and name but you didn't forget
I don't know currency which is another
property is this symmetric between class
one and class two or not yes not always
what do you mean not always it depends
if you don't specify left or right as
the fourth argument yes so what color is
saying is that there are different types
of joints yeah certain types of joints I
don't just don't think this is the right
way to think about it I think we should
be thinking about it in terms of what
how we can explain this to people who
didn't spend years working with SQL
databases assume the thing is that
people as I was explaining this demo and
there are some example below a lot of
these things that we do with joins can
be done with relations that means
walking this property pass the point is
that if somebody is familiar with this
and it's trying to accept that it's
familiar with this they might as well
just be writing SQL no except that there
are at least four major dialects and
they will instead of writing SQL they
will just say then we should make the
names exactly the same as in SQL and it
should be like the as you know database
link that's what we should do I think I
mean Steven there are a lot of things
that you can do without the need for
joints but it gets to the point where
things become complex enough that you
might need to join and I don't see why
should obfuscate this concept we're not
we're trying to make it less obfuscated
so let's go through again what this is
doing this is saying given the things in
class one
we are saying that we're seeing things
in class one that associate the things
in class one with things in class - is
that correct yes same property that
property this is incorrectly written
because that property no the property of
glass one you see and it can be the same
property in this case this is the exact
the third usage case okay but what I was
explaining that notebook if you look
just below is that in this case you can
get rid of the drain across and perform
this operation much more simply
simulations not that far below which
relations data set of aunty value person
who named entity function blah blah blah
that one yeah the same dataset so it can
be done more simply if you walk the
property
the track is this what is this what is
that oh that has been renamed not now
that is called Nash mission entity okay
I mean that's just a thing that's just
some random field in that in that some
table of law that's an orthogonal is a
name for the random field in the table
discrimination and there's a new concept
the concept that we have string a new
concept and we talked about it I mean
we've been going on with this for two
hours and we are all super tired we went
through these three weeks ago it's not a
new concept where is a short commented
it's not yet documented but you went
through the names you said you didn't
like relation and we renamed it 20 so
that is when there is a foreign key the
naked foreign keys combination and when
are pointing you you're dressing it with
the the entity head so that you can
actually keep extracting properties
there
is going to be called nation - and why
is it done as part of the string name
why is that not something that is that
is has a symbolic wrapper because
properties have string means and this
should behave just like any there are
properties like dated that do not that
have a symbol it is not a separate
property it's just a qualifier for
property okay but isn't this a qualifier
as well no it's it's a separate property
you might want to extract them
separately and there are cases where
there is no regional property you can
piggyback on because it's the reverse
relation okay so anyway in with the
machinery of relation you can get rid of
joints in many cases and that's one of
the biggest selling points of frameworks
like Django for example John both didn't
have explicit joins at the beginning
because you can do a lot of things
without them not all of them but a lot
of them okay all right so listen we've
got the first thing we need to do next
time is to unscramble this database
connection database inspect relational
database object thing okay my feeling is
that the right way to do this is to have
a database connect and a database
disconnect if that's what you're in fact
want no that's that's really not needed
because the connection is lazy so only
when you're performing an entity value
call then you connect but usually it
stays disconnected on the other hand
disconnecting might be necessary um
otherwise sometimes database gets
blocked
okay okay I just add those topics for
discussion for the next meeting and I
already asked Alex to schedule the
meeting next this week listen it's not
just this week that this is gonna hold
up this release if we don't get this
sorted out now this probably has to be
tomorrow okay okay which means he's
gonna have to rearrange a ton of stuff
okay
okay all right I will see you guys and
people on the livestream we're about to
actually start another discussion about
neural networks and which will also be
live-streamed and you're very welcome to
join us and I will push back all the
stuff from this and okay if you can have
a think about this database connection
thing and try and inspect and so on and
try and come up with a suggestion that
will be really helpful because this
thing the sequence that you're showing
me of entity register I mean essentially
that is a really horrifying sequence
because what you're doing there this
entity register of entities store and
basically the full stack is entity
register of entity store
of database inspect of database
connection just us you can just bust
that a bit if you're not trying to do
anything fancy you can us that abyss
connects from directly to entity store
okay that makes more sense why not see
and there are business out there which
have hundreds of tables and giant so why
not put in the database connection
wrapper why not put the thing that says
why not put debt in database connections
say which tables you care about that's
that's definitely the wrong place
because database connection is just the
place where you put the URL and
otherwise look at what's gonna happen
here otherwise what you've got to do is
you're gonna say relational database I
wouldn't mind have extra every next
argument in the relational database
object to the discount then what it
looks like is that which is really weird
since the the full form of the
relational database object s database
connection has the second argument maybe
we can ever a relational database object
be its own constructor and you pass it a
list of in the first argument the list
of the tables you want I think this is
what Stephen was suggesting yeah we can
take a body tomorrow and figure out Isis
has multiple different concepts in it
right if this if we could just do if it
was just this ok database connection of
that , you know tables or whatever now
that would be to me a fairly clean piece
of code which actually means something
but what about if we put it in the
entity store first argument not first
argument not the first argument but
still in the problems this is that one
and the same connection can be used in
different circumstances to extract
different sets of tables
okay well okay so then here's another
suggestion okay here's another
suggestion what about this
and that could probably work wait a
second doesn't that abyss connection
have some values for exacting properties
listen listen listen think about this
guy's but think about this whole
sequence here because it doesn't you
know something like this seems civilized
and make some sense by the time you've
got this in the middle at least that
name doesn't make much sense to me
and this sure doesn't make sense
database inspect like it's gonna bring
up some GUI and that absolutely doesn't
make sense
seon-ah entities empty store already can
take a list of tables in the first
argument to filter out the things so I
mean it's already I don't know if it's
documented but for well it's not
documented for this but if you look at
the structure of the NT store which
probably wasn't that demo as well you
can decide to have an NT store which
only cares about a few of the of the
tables and so we can actually optimize
the things so that we don't inspect
actually the obvious thing to do look
with this entity sort of type it's a one
argument form we could have an initial
argument which is a database that is an
optional initial argument I don't like
the idea of having these disembodied
tables is the first argument so in other
words the way it would look is you could
enter this store of database comma you
know tables no it's it we already have
that it's just the other way around no
I'm saying I think it should be this way
round because entity store right now can
just be a type right but that's the case
where it's in memory and it doesn't need
to specify yeah but what we had decided
is that the the database object whatever
it is the connection is the second
argument of the NC store and I agreed
that somehow choosing a specific back
end is the optional operation in the
second argument so that would be my
preference can you scroll down in that
in that demo not I got a girl's got to
go I'm sorry to be continued hopefully
tomorrow okay all right seal